أهلاً بكم مجدداً في سلسلة فهم المعلومات والحوسبة الكمية، اسمي John watus وأنا المدير التقني للتعليم في IBM
Quantum، هذا الدرس رقم 14 من السلسلة وهو الدرس الثاني من الوحدة الرابعة التي تتناول تصحيح الأخطاء
الكمية. في الدرس السابق ألقينا نظرة أولى على تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية بما في ذلك شيفرة Shore ذات التسعة qubit التي تثبت أن
تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية ممكن نظرياً. كذلك ناقشنا تقطيع الأخطاء الذي يتيح لنا
تصحيح أخطاء كمية عشوائية على الـ qubit عن طريق إسقاطها فعلياً على انقلابات البت وانقلابات
الطور. في هذا الدرس سنناقش صيغة المُثبِّت وهي أداة رياضية يمكننا من خلالها
تحديد وتحليل فئة واسعة من شيفرات تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية المعروفة بشيفرات المُثبِّت. وهذا يشمل شيفرة Shore ذات التسعة qubit
بالإضافة إلى أمثلة كثيرة أخرى تشمل شيفرات من المرجح أن تكون أنسب بكثير لأجهزة الحوسبة
الكمية الفعلية من شيفرة Shore. ليست كل شيفرة تصحيح أخطاء كمية هي شيفرة مُثبِّت، لكن كثيراً منها كذلك
بما في ذلك كل مثال سنراه في هذه السلسلة. هناك بالتأكيد شيفرات تصحيح أخطاء كمية مثيرة للاهتمام
ومفيدة محتملة ليست شيفرات مُثبِّت، لكنها تميل لأن تكون أكثر تعقيداً، وفي كل الأحوال لا شك
أن صيغة المُثبِّت هي حجر أساس في أساسات تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية وسنعتمد
عليها بشكل كبير لبقية الوحدة. إليكم نظرة عامة موجزة على الدرس: سنبدأ بمناقشة قصيرة
لمصفوفات Pauli والجداءات التنسورية لمصفوفات Pauli التي يمكنها تمثيل كل من العمليات على الـ qubit وكذلك
قياسات الـ qubit كما سأوضح، وفي هذا السياق نشير إليها غالباً بالمرصودات. ثم سنعود لنلقي
نظرة ثانية على شيفرة التكرار وسنرى كيف يمكننا وصفها من خلال عمليات ومرصودات Pauli، وهذا سيُفيد
ويقود إلى مناقشة عامة لشيفرات المُثبِّت تشمل عدة أمثلة وخصائص أساسية لشيفرات
المُثبِّت وكيف يمكننا تنفيذ المهام الأساسية من ترميز واكتشاف الأخطاء وتصحيح تلك
الأخطاء. سنبدأ الدرس بمناقشة موجزة لعمليات Pauli بشكل رئيسي لتمهيد الطريق لصيغة
المُثبِّت ولكن أيضاً لملاحظة بعض الحقائق المهمة وتأسيس بعض المصطلحات الأساسية. أولاً، إليكم مصفوفات
Pauli بما فيها مصفوفة الوحدة 2×2 وكذلك مصفوفات Pauli الثلاث غير الوحدوية التي سنرمز لها بـ
X وY وZ الكبيرة طوال بقية السلسلة. جميع هذه المصفوفات الأربع وحدوية وهرميتية معاً، ويمكننا
ربطها بعمليات على qubit واحد بما في ذلك عمليات قد نختار تنفيذها وكذلك أخطاء كما
ناقشنا في الدرس السابق. مصفوفات Pauli غير الوحدوية X وY وZ تتبادل عكسياً مع بعضها البعض
بمعنى أن XY يساوي سالب 1 ضرب YX، وXZ يساوي سالب ZX، وYZ يساوي
سالب ZY. ويمكنكم التحقق من هذه العلاقات بسهولة بإجراء عمليات الضرب. علاقات التبادل العكسي
هذه بسيطة جداً لكنها بالغة الأهمية في صيغة المُثبِّت وغيرها، وتحديداً
كما سنرى فإن إشارات السالب التي تظهر عندما نبدّل ترتيب مصفوفتي Pauli مختلفتين غير وحدويتين في جداء تتوافق تماماً مع
اكتشاف الأخطاء في صيغة المُثبِّت. لدينا أيضاً قواعد الضرب المدرجة هنا: كل
مصفوفة Pauli هي معكوسة نفسها وهذا يتوافق مع كونها وحدوية وهرميتية معاً، وإذا ضربت أي مصفوفتي Pauli مختلفتين غير وحدويتين
ببعضهما ستحصل دائماً على موجب أو سالب i مضروباً في مصفوفة Pauli الثالثة غير
الوحدوية المتبقية. وبالأخص، بتجاهل الطور الشامل، Y تكافئ X ضرب Z وهذا يفسر تركيزنا على أخطاء X وZ في
تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية. X تمثل انقلاب بت، وZ تمثل انقلاب طور، وبالتالي بتجاهل الطور الشامل Y تمثل
حدوث كلا الخطأين على نفس الـ qubit. هذه المصفوفات الأربع جميعها تمثل
عمليات أو أخطاء أو غياب خطأ على qubit واحد، لكن من المفيد غالباً أخذ الجداء التنسوري بينها
لتنفيذ عمليات أو أخطاء على عدة qubit. كمصطلح، عندما نشير إلى عملية Pauli على n من الـ qubit
نقصد الجداء التنسوري لأي n من مصفوفات Pauli مثل الأمثلة المعروضة
هنا. من الشائع أيضاً استخدام مصطلح عملية Pauli عندما يكون هناك طور شامل، لكن لإبقاء الأمور بسيطة قدر الإمكان
سأستخدم مصطلح عملية Pauli ليعني ببساطة الجداء التنسوري لمصفوفات Pauli. وزن عملية Pauli على n من الـ qubit
هو ببساطة عدد مصفوفات Pauli غير الوحدوية في الجداء التنسوري. مثلاً الجداء التنسوري n-مرة
لمصفوفة الوحدة 2×2 مع نفسها هو عملية Pauli بوزن صفر. والجداء التنسوري لمصفوفتي Pauli من نوع X
مع مجموعة من مصفوفات الوحدة له وزن اثنان، وهكذا. بشكل حدسي، وزن عملية Pauli على n من الـ qubit
هو عدد الـ qubit التي تعمل عليها بشكل غير تافه. ومن المعتاد أن شيفرات تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية تُصمَّم
بحيث تستطيع اكتشاف وتصحيح الأخطاء الممثلة بعمليات Pauli حتى وزن معين. يمكننا
التفكير في عمليات Pauli بطرق مختلفة بما في ذلك كعمليات تُنفَّذ عمداً بواسطة gate كمية وكذلك
كأخطاء، وسنرى قريباً أن عمليات Pauli يمكنها وصف القياسات أيضاً. أحياناً يكون من المفيد
التفكير في عمليات Pauli كمولدات لمجموعات معينة بالمعنى الجبري الذي قد تعرفونه
إذا كنتم على دراية بنظرية الزمر. إذا لم تكونوا على دراية بنظرية الزمر فلا بأس، فهي ليست ضرورية حقاً
لهذا الدرس، لكن إذا كنتم مهتمين بدراسة تصحيح الأخطاء الكمية بعمق أكبر فقد تجدون أن بعض
نظرية الزمر الأساسية مفيدة جداً لذلك. على أي حال، لنفترض أن P1 إلى PR هي عمليات Pauli على n من الـ qubit
فـ P1 عملية Pauli على n من الـ qubit وP2 عملية Pauli على n من الـ qubit وهكذا. عندما نشير إلى المجموعة المولَّدة بواسطة
P1 إلى PR نقصد مجموعة كل المصفوفات التي يمكننا الحصول عليها بضرب هذه المصفوفات ببعضها بأي
تركيبة وبأي ترتيب نختاره، مع أخذ كل واحدة بعدد المرات الذي نريده. سنرى بعض الأمثلة بعد
قليل، لكن أولاً دعوني أذكر الترميز الذي نستخدمه للدلالة على هذه المجموعة المولَّدة بواسطة P1 إلى PR وهو
P1 إلى PR مفصولة بفواصل داخل أقواس زاوية. يبدو الأمر وكأننا قد نخلط بسهولة
بين هذا الترميز وترميز Dirac لكن هذا لا يحدث عادة، وهذا هو الترميز التقليدي في نظرية
الزمر. إليكم مثالاً على المجموعة المولَّدة بواسطة X وY وZ فـ n يساوي واحداً في هذا المثال لأنه لا توجد
جداءات تنسورية ونأخذ مصفوفات Pauli الثلاث غير الوحدوية كمولدات. يتبين أن هناك
16 مصفوفة يمكن توليدها بتكوين جداءات تتضمن هذه المصفوفات الثلاث ويمكنكم استنتاج ذلك
من قواعد الضرب التي رأيناها سابقاً. تحديداً يمكننا بالطبع الحصول على X وY وZ وكذلك الوحدة
وفي الواقع يمكننا أيضاً الحصول على أي من هذه المصفوفات الأربع مضروبة في 1 أو i أو سالب 1 أو سالب i وهذا
كل شيء. هذه المجموعة تُعرف عادة بزمرة Pauli. يمكننا أيضاً النظر في المجموعة
المولَّدة بواسطة X وZ فقط، وسنحصل على نصف زمرة Pauli في هذه الحالة
ومثال أخير على الأقل حالياً، يمكننا النظر في المجموعة المولَّدة بواسطة X تنسور X وZ تنسور Z فـ n يساوي
اثنين في هذه الحالة وسنحصل على أربعة عناصر فقط هذه المرة، وذلك لأن X تنسور X وZ تنسور Z
يتبادلان مع بعضهما البعض. مصفوفات Pauli وعمليات Pauli على n من الـ qubit بشكل عام تصف
عمليات وحدوية سواء كانت أخطاء أو عمليات مقصودة، لكنها تصف أيضاً
القياسات. لنكون أكثر دقة، بدءاً بمصفوفات Pauli الثلاث غير الوحدوية فقط، يمكننا ربط كل من هذه
المصفوفات بقياس إسقاطي مُعرَّف بدلالة قيمها الذاتية ومتجهاتها الذاتية. وهنا على الشاشة لدينا
التحليلات الطيفية لهذه المصفوفات التي ستساعد في توضيح ذلك. في جوهر الأمر، عندما نشير إلى قياس X
أو قياس Y أو قياس Z فنقصد القياس الإسقاطي المُعرَّف بالإسقاطات
على الفضاءات الذاتية لهذه المصفوفات، وعادة نعتبر القيم الذاتية هي نتائج القياس
المقابلة. مثلاً، قياس X هو قياس بالنسبة لأساس زائد
ناقص لـ qubit واحد، أو بدلاً من ذلك يمكننا وصفه بالمجموعة المحتوية على الإسقاطات كت زائد برا زائد وكت
ناقص برا ناقص. قياس Z من ناحية أخرى ليس سوى قياس بالأساس
القياسي، وإن كما قلت نربط أحياناً القيم الذاتية بنتائج القياس، وإذا فعلنا ذلك
فالنتائج هي زائد واحد وناقص واحد بدلاً من 0 و1 على التوالي. يمكننا فعلاً أن نفعل شيئاً
مشابهاً لمصفوفات هرميتية عشوائية، ومصطلح المرصود يُستخدم عادة في هذه الحالة. لعمليات Pauli
على الـ qubit وعمليات Pauli على n من الـ qubit بشكل عام، يمكننا إجراء مثل هذه القياسات بشكل غير هدّام باستخدام
تقدير الطور. ولأكون متأكداً أن هذا المخطط واضح، هنا نجري القياسات بشكل غير هدّام على
الـ qubit العلوي بينما الـ qubit السفلي يُهيَّأ دائماً في حالة زائد أو بعبارة أخرى Hadamard مطبَّق على حالة
صفر لأن هذه هي طريقة عمل تقدير الطور. لاحظوا أنه لأن القيم الذاتية
هي فقط زائد واحد وناقص واحد في هذه الحالة، نحتاج فقط إلى qubit تحكم واحد وهو الـ qubit السفلي في هذا
المخطط. أي عدد أكثر من ذلك سيكون مجرد هدر لأن هناك بت دقة واحد فقط يجب القلق بشأنه. القيمة الذاتية
إما زائد واحد أو ناقص واحد والقياس مثالي بالفعل هكذا. نتيجة هذا القياس بالمناسبة
أي قياس الأساس القياسي في الـ circuit ستكون صفر لنتيجة القيمة الذاتية زائد واحد
التي تقابل حالة زائد في حالة مرصود X، والنتيجة واحد لنتيجة القيمة الذاتية ناقص واحد
أو حالة ناقص في هذه الحالة. كل ما قلته للتو يمتد بشكل طبيعي لعمليات Pauli على n من الـ qubit
بشرط أن نتذكر أننا عندما نفكر في مرصود فنحن نتحدث عن قياس القيم الذاتية
وليس القياس بالنسبة لأساس من المتجهات الذاتية. مثلاً تأملوا عملية
Pauli على qubit اثنين Z تنسور Z. مرة أخرى هناك قيمتان ذاتيتان زائد واحد وناقص واحد فالقياس
يُوصَف بإسقاطين. لاحظوا بالأخص أن القياس المرتبط بهذا
المرصود ليس نفس قياس كلا الـ qubit بقياس Z أو بعبارة أخرى قياس بالأساس القياسي، بل هو قياس إسقاطي ذو نتيجتين
حيث الإسقاطات على الفضاءات المولَّدة بكل المتجهات الذاتية المقابلة
لكل من القيمتين الذاتيتين زائد واحد وناقص واحد. طريقة أخرى للتفكير في هذا هي أن القيم الذاتية للجداء
التنسوري هي جداءات القيم الذاتية للمصفوفات الفردية التي نأخذ جداءها التنسوري، ولأن
سالب 1 ضرب سالب 1 يساوي موجب 1 ضرب موجب 1 مثلاً، فإن هذا القياس لا يميز
بين 00 و11. فلو قسنا مثلاً حالة Bell في زائد بالقياس المُوصَف بهذا المرصود
سنكون متأكدين من الحصول على النتيجة المقابلة للقيمة الذاتية زائد واحد
والحالة ستبقى دون تغيير، على عكس الانهيار إلى 00 أو 11 وهو ما سيحدث لو
أجرينا قياسات الأساس القياسي على الـ qubit الاثنين. إذاً قياس Z تنسور Z ليس
نفس الشيء كإجراء قياسين Z بشكل مستقل، لكن يمكننا فعلاً إجراء قياسات كهذه باستخدام تقدير
الطور بنفس الطريقة تماماً كما سبق باستخدام qubit تحكم واحد كما هو موضح في مخطط الـ circuit الذي
يتعمم لأي عملية Pauli على n من الـ qubit بدلاً من Z تنسور Z. عندما تكون لدينا مصفوفات Z من Pauli فقط
يمكننا تبسيط الـ circuit هكذا، وما يكشفه هذا - وهو واضح أيضاً من الإسقاطات التي تُعرِّف
القياس - هو أن إجراء قياس Z تنسور Z على qubit اثنين يكافئ قياس تكافؤهما
بالتفكير بدلالة الأساس القياسي. وهذا يتعمم للجداء التنسوري لأي عدد من مصفوفات Z من Pauli
بعد ذلك سنلقي نظرة ثانية على شيفرة التكرار ذات الثلاثة بتات، هذه المرة بصياغتها بدلالة عمليات
Pauli. هذا سيكون أول مثال بسيط نوعاً ما لشيفرة مُثبِّت وسنناقش كيفية تعميم هذا
المفهوم قريباً، لكن من المفيد أن نرى كيف يعمل في هذه الحالة البسيطة أولاً. تذكروا أنه عند تطبيق
شيفرة التكرار ذات الثلاثة بتات على الـ qubit نُرمِّز حالة qubit معينة ألفا 0 زائد بيتا 1 كـ ألفا 000 زائد بيتا 111
وسنسمي هذا الترميز ذا الثلاثة qubit باسم ساي للسهولة. إذاً بالتعريف ساي هو ترميز صالح لحالة
qubit من ثلاثة qubit، لكن إذا أردنا التحقق من ذلك يكفي التحقق من صحة المعادلتين التاليتين.
المعادلة الأولى تنص على أن تطبيق عمليات Z على أقصى يسار qubit اثنين من ساي لا يغير شيئاً في ساي، أي أن
ساي هو متجه ذاتي لـ Z تنسور Z تنسور الوحدة أو اختصاراً ZZ وحدة بقيمة ذاتية واحد. والمعادلة
الثانية مشابهة إلا أن عمليات Z تُطبَّق على أقصى يمين qubit اثنين. الفكرة هي أنه إذا فكرنا في ساي
كتركيبة خطية من حالات الأساس القياسي، فإن المعادلة الأولى تعني أنه لا يمكن أن تكون لدينا معاملات غير صفرية إلا لحالات الأساس القياسي
التي يكون تكافؤ أقصى يسار بتين فيها زوجياً أو بعبارة مكافئة متساويين. والمعادلة الثانية تعني أنه لا يمكن أن تكون لدينا
معاملات غير صفرية إلا لحالات الأساس القياسي التي يكون تكافؤ أقصى يمين بتين فيها زوجياً. طريقة أخرى للتفكير في هذا
هي اعتبار عمليتي Pauli هاتين كمرصودين، ولو قسنا هذين المرصودين باستخدام الـ circuit
المبسط الذي ذكرته قبل قليل لكنا متأكدين من الحصول على نتيجة قياس مقابلة لقيم ذاتية زائد واحد
لأن ساي هو متجه ذاتي لكلا المرصودين بقيمة ذاتية واحد. لكن هذه النسخة المبسطة من الـ circuit المُجمَّع
لقياس المرصودين بشكل مستقل ليس سوى circuit فحص التكافؤ لشيفرة التكرار ذات الثلاثة
بتات. وهكذا نرى أن معادلتينا معاً تكافئان خرج circuit فحص التكافؤ 00
وهو المتلازمة التي تشير إلى عدم اكتشاف أخطاء. عمليات Pauli على ثلاثة qubit
ZZ وحدة ووحدة ZZ تُسمى مولدات المُثبِّت لهذه الشيفرة، ومُثبِّت الشيفرة هو المجموعة
المولَّدة بواسطة مولدات المُثبِّت. هذه المجموعة، المُثبِّت، هي كائن رياضي أساسي
مرتبط بهذه الشيفرة وسنناقش المزيد عن الدور الذي يلعبه مع استمرار الدرس. في الوقت الحالي
سأشير فقط إلى أنه كان بإمكاننا اختيار مولدات مختلفة، مثلاً كان يمكننا اختيار Z وحدة Z بدلاً من أي
من المولدين اللذين اخترناهما وستكون الشيفرة والمُثبِّت نفسهما تماماً. بعد ذلك سننظر في اكتشاف انقلاب
البت لشيفرة التكرار ذات الثلاثة بتات مع التركيز على التفاعلات والعلاقات بين عمليات
Pauli المعنية، وتحديداً مولدات المُثبِّت والأخطاء نفسها. لنفترض أننا رمَّزنا
qubit باستخدام شيفرة التكرار ذات الثلاثة بتات وحدث خطأ انقلاب بت على أقصى يسار qubit. هذا يتسبب في تحويل حالتنا ساي
وفقاً لتأثير عملية X أو خطأ X على أقصى يسار qubit. كما نعلم مسبقاً يمكننا اكتشاف
هذا الخطأ بإجراء فحوصات التكافؤ لشيفرة التكرار ذات الثلاثة بتات أو بشكل مكافئ يمكننا قياس
الترميز بشكل غير هدّام بمعاملة مولدات المُثبِّت كمرصودات. لنبدأ بأول
مولد مُثبِّت ونرى ماذا يحدث. حالتنا تأثرت بخطأ X ونريد أن نفهم
كيف يتأثر قياس مولد المُثبِّت كمرصود بهذا الخطأ. X وZ يتبادلان عكسياً بينما
كل شيء يتبادل مع مصفوفة الوحدة، وبالتالي يتضح أن ZZ وحدة يتبادل عكسياً مع X وحدة
وحدة. فنحصل على إشارة سالب عند تغيير الترتيب. ونعلم أيضاً أن ZZ وحدة لا يغير شيئاً في ساي
لأن ساي هو ترميز صالح لـ qubit والترميزات الصالحة هي دائماً متجهات ذاتية بقيمة زائد واحد لكلا مولدي
المُثبِّت. هذا يتركنا مع سالب X وحدة وحدة مطبقة على ساي، وبالتالي X وحدة وحدة مطبقة على
ساي هي متجه ذاتي لـ ZZ وحدة بقيمة ذاتية سالب واحد. يمكننا أيضاً فعل شيء مشابه
مع مولد المُثبِّت الثاني، لكن هذه المرة الخطأ يتبادل مع مولد المُثبِّت وبالتالي حالتنا
المُفسَدة هي مرة أخرى متجه ذاتي لمولد المُثبِّت لكن هذه المرة القيمة الذاتية موجبة
واحد. إذاً حالتنا المُفسَدة هي متجه ذاتي لكلا مولدي المُثبِّت وما إذا كانت القيمة الذاتية زائد واحد أو
ناقص واحد يتحدد بما إذا كان الخطأ يتبادل أو يتبادل عكسياً مع كل مولد مُثبِّت. للأول
الخطأ ومولد المُثبِّت يتبادلان عكسياً، وللثاني يتبادلان، وسيكون دائماً أحدهما لأن أي عمليتي
Pauli إما تتبادلان أو تتبادلان عكسياً. في الوقت نفسه الحالة الفعلية ساي لا تلعب دوراً مهماً
هنا سوى كون مولدات المُثبِّت تعمل بشكل تافه على هذه الحالة. فعندما نفكر في
اكتشاف الأخطاء لا نحتاج حقاً للقلق بشأن الحالة المُرمَّزة المحددة. كل ما يهم هو ما إذا كان الخطأ يتبادل أو يتبادل عكسياً
مع كل مولد مُثبِّت. فلننشئ جدولاً يحتوي على صف لكل مولد مُثبِّت
وعمود لكل خطأ. هنا أدرجت فقط الأخطاء المقابلة لانقلاب بت واحد بالإضافة
إلى عدم وجود خطأ على الإطلاق والمُشار إليه بالوحدة الموضوعة كجداء تنسوري مع نفسها ثلاث مرات. يمكننا إضافة أعمدة أخرى لأخطاء أخرى لو أردنا
لكن الآن سنركز على هذه الأخطاء فقط. القيمة في الجدول إما زائد واحد أو ناقص واحد بحسب
ما إذا كان الخطأ ومولد المُثبِّت يتبادلان أو يتبادلان عكسياً. فلكل خطأ في الجدول يمكننا النظر في
العمود المقابل لنرى كيف سيحوّل ذلك الخطأ أي ترميز معطى إلى متجه ذاتي بقيمة زائد واحد أو ناقص واحد
لكل مولد مُثبِّت. هذه الأعمدة تقابل تماماً المتلازمة التي سنحصل عليها من
فحوصات التكافؤ المكافئة للقياسات غير الهدّامة لمولدات المُثبِّت
كمرصودات. بالطبع القيم في هذا الجدول هي زائد واحد وناقص واحد بدلاً من أصفار وواحدات على التوالي
وإذا فضلتم يمكنكم التفكير في المتلازمات كسلاسل ثنائية مقابلة بدلاً من أعمدة من الموجب واحد والسالب واحد. لكن هناك
تقابل مباشر. ولجعل الصلة بين المتلازمات والقيم الذاتية أوضح وأكثر مباشرة
سأشير إلى متجهات الموجب واحد والسالب واحد هذه كمتلازمات. كما سبق فإن المتلازمات تخبرنا
بشيء عن أي خطأ حدث، وبالأخص إذا علمنا أن أحد هذه الأخطاء الأربعة الممكنة
قد حدث فإن المتلازمة تدلنا على أيها حدث ويمكننا تصحيحه بتطبيق الخطأ مرة أخرى إذا
أردنا. بعد ذلك سأقول المزيد قليلاً عن المتلازمات وبالأخص سنلقي نظرة أقرب على
جوانبها الجبرية. ترميزاتنا هي حالات من ثلاثة qubit وبالتالي هي متجهات وحدة في فضاء
متجهي مركب ثماني الأبعاد. وما تفعله المتلازمات الأربع الممكنة هو تقسيم هذا الفضاء ثماني الأبعاد
إلى أربعة فضاءات فرعية ثنائية الأبعاد، بمعنى أن المتجهات في أي من هذه الفضاءات الفرعية ستعطينا دائماً نفس
المتلازمة. بمزيد من التفصيل يوضح هذا المخطط كيف يُقسَّم الفضاء ثماني الأبعاد.
كل مولد مُثبِّت يقسم الفضاء إلى فضاءين فرعيين متساويي البُعد وهما فضاء المتجهات الذاتية لقيمة زائد واحد
وفضاء المتجهات الذاتية لقيمة ناقص واحد. مثلاً المتجهات الذاتية لقيمة زائد واحد لـ ZZ وحدة هي التركيبات الخطية
لحالات الأساس القياسي التي تكافؤ أقصى يسار بتين فيها زوجي، والمتجهات الذاتية لقيمة ناقص واحد هي التركيبات
الخطية لحالات الأساس القياسي التي تكافؤ أقصى يسار بتين فيها فردي. والوضع مشابه لمولد
المُثبِّت الآخر إلا أنه أقصى يمين بتين بدلاً من أقصى يسار بتين. إذاً هذه الفضاءات الفرعية الأربعة سهلة
الوصف في هذه الحالة نظراً لأن هذه شيفرة بسيطة جداً. وبالأخص الفضاء الفرعي
المقابل للمتلازمة زائد واحد زائد واحد هو الفضاء المولَّد بكت 000 وكت 111 وهو فضاء الترميزات الصالحة
ويُسمى فضاء الشيفرة. وبشكل عام الفضاءات مولَّدة بحالات الأساس القياسي
الموضحة في المربعات المقابلة. رغم أنه ليس بالضرورة واضحاً أو سهل الرؤية، فإن المتلازمات
تقسم أيضاً كل عمليات Pauli على ثلاثة qubit التي تمثل أخطاء Pauli المحتملة إلى أربع مجموعات متساوية الحجم
بحسب المتلازمة التي سيسببها كل خطأ. مثلاً أي عملية Pauli
تتبادل مع كلا مولدي المُثبِّت تنتج المتلازمة زائد واحد زائد واحد، ومن بين 64 عملية Pauli ممكنة على ثلاثة
qubit هناك بالضبط 16 منها في هذه الفئة بما فيها الثلاث المذكورة على الشاشة. وكذلك الأمر للمتلازمات الثلاث الأخرى
هذا ليس واضحاً لكنه صحيح. وهذه الخاصية الأساسية بأن المتلازمات تقسم كلاً من فضاء الحالات
الذي تعيش فيه الترميزات وكل أخطاء Pauli الممكنة في الفضاء إلى قطع متساوية الحجم هي شيء
صحيح بشكل عام لشيفرات المُثبِّت التي سنعرّفها بدقة قريباً. ورغم أنها ملاحظة جانبية بشكل أساسي
في هذه المرحلة، تجدر الإشارة إلى أن عمليات Pauli التي تتبادل مع كلا مولدي المُثبِّت أو بشكل مكافئ
عمليات Pauli التي تنتج المتلازمة زائد واحد زائد واحد لكنها ليست متناسبة مع عناصر المُثبِّت تتصرف تماماً
كعمليات Pauli على qubit منطقي واحد قمنا بترميزه. مثلاً XXX تتبادل مع
كلا مولدي المُثبِّت لكنها ليست متناسبة مع أي عنصر من المُثبِّت، وفعلاً من الواضح لو فكرت
في هذه الشيفرة لحظة أن تأثير هذه العملية على ترميز يكافئ gate من نوع X على
الـ qubit المنطقي الذي تم ترميزه. ومرة أخرى هذا شيء يتعمم لجميع شيفرات المُثبِّت. الآن حان الوقت لتعريف شيفرات
المُثبِّت بشكل عام. والطريقة هي أن نفعل شيئاً مماثلاً تماماً لما ناقشناه للتو بخصوص
شيفرة التكرار ذات الثلاثة بتات لكن نختار مولدات مُثبِّت مختلفة سنشير إليها جميعاً بـ P1
إلى PR لغرض هذا الشرح. يجب أن تكون مولدات المُثبِّت هذه جميعها عمليات Pauli على n من الـ qubit
حيث n هو عدد الـ qubit المستخدمة للترميز. ولا يمكننا اختيار أي مجموعة عشوائية من مولدات المُثبِّت فهي
يجب أن تستوفي بعض الشروط الأساسية. أولاً يجب أن تتبادل جميع مولدات المُثبِّت مع بعضها
البعض. في حالة شيفرة التكرار ذات الثلاثة بتات لم نهتم بملاحظة ذلك لكنه سهل الملاحظة أن ZZ وحدة ووحدة
ZZ يتبادلان فعلاً لأن Z يتبادل مع نفسه وكل شيء يتبادل مع
الوحدة. لشيفرات المُثبِّت ذات المولدات الأكثر تعقيداً من ناحية أخرى، بما في ذلك الشيفرات التي تظهر فيها
كل من X وZ في مولدات المُثبِّت، هذا شرط مهم يجب
التحقق منه. إحدى طرق التفكير في الحاجة لهذا الشرط هي أننا سنتعامل مع مولدات المُثبِّت كمرصودات وباشتراط
تبادلها جميعاً نضمن أن ترتيب إجراء هذه القياسات لا
يهم. ثانياً يجب أن تشكّل مولدات المُثبِّت ما يُسمى مجموعة مولدة صغرى، بمعنى أنه لو أزلنا أي
واحد منها سنحصل على مُثبِّت أصغر. وإحدى طرق التعبير عن هذا رياضياً موضحة هنا على
الشاشة. بالمعنى الدقيق هذا الشرط ليس ضرورياً حقاً لطريقة عمل شيفرة المُثبِّت عملياً
وأحياناً يكون من المنطقي التفكير في مجموعات مولدة غير صغرى كما سنرى في الدرس التالي. لكن
لغرض تحليل شيفرات المُثبِّت وشرح خصائصها سنفترض أن هذا الشرط
متحقق. في الأساس هذا الشرط يضمن أن كل مرصود نقيسه للحصول على المتلازمة يضيف
معلومات عن الأخطاء المحتملة بدلاً من أن يكون زائداً عن الحاجة ويعطي نتائج يمكن استنتاجها بسهولة من مولدات المُثبِّت الأخرى
كمرصودات. وأخيراً يجب أن يكون هناك على الأقل متجه غير صفري واحد مُثبَّت بواسطة جميع
مولدات المُثبِّت، ويتبين أن هذا يكافئ اشتراط أن سالب واحد ضرب الوحدة على n من الـ qubit
ليس موجوداً في المُثبِّت. هذا ليس واضحاً لكن المقصود هو أنه من الممكن اختيار مجموعة مولدة صغرى
من عمليات Pauli على n من الـ qubit تتبادل جميعها مع بعضها البعض ومع ذلك لا يوجد متجه يكون في آن واحد متجهاً ذاتياً بقيمة زائد واحد
لجميعها. ولا نريد أن نشغل أنفسنا بهذا الاحتمال لأن الشيفرات التي لا تحتوي على ترميزات صالحة ليست
مثيرة للاهتمام. إذاً هذه هي المتطلبات على مولدات المُثبِّت لشيفرة مُثبِّت، وإذا كانت لدينا مجموعة مولدات
تستوفي هذه الشروط فلدينا شيفرة مُثبِّت صالحة ويمكننا النظر في خصائصها. هناك العديد من
شيفرات المُثبِّت المختلفة ذات الخصائص المتنوعة التي تجعلها مثيرة للاهتمام أو لا، لكنها جميعاً تستوفي خصائص أساسية
معينة تذكّرنا بالخصائص التي لاحظناها بالفعل لشيفرة التكرار ذات الثلاثة بتات.
سنلقي نظرة على بعض الأمثلة قريباً لكن قبل ذلك دعوني أذكر أنه عندما نشير إلى فضاء شيفرة المُثبِّت نقصد الفضاء الفرعي
من فضاء الحالات على n من الـ qubit الذي يتضمن كل متجه يكون في آن واحد متجهاً ذاتياً بقيمة زائد واحد لكل واحد من
مولدات المُثبِّت. هذا هو الفضاء الفرعي من فضاء الحالات على n من الـ qubit الذي تعيش فيه الترميزات الصالحة وسيكون لدينا المزيد
لنقوله عن هذا الفضاء الفرعي مع استمرار الدرس. الآن لنلقِ نظرة على بعض أمثلة شيفرات
المُثبِّت. إليكم المثال الذي ناقشناه بالفعل: شيفرة التكرار العادية ذات الثلاثة بتات. ويمكننا أيضاً التعبير عن
النسخة المعدلة من تلك الشيفرة من الدرس السابق التي يمكنها اكتشاف انقلاب طور بدلاً من انقلاب بت كشيفرة مُثبِّت كما هو موضح
هنا. هذه المرة مولدات المُثبِّت تقيس مرصودات XX بدلاً من مرصودات ZZ فهذه في الأساس
فحوصات تكافؤ في أساس زائد ناقص بدلاً من الأساس القياسي. في كلتا الحالتين يمكننا
أن نرى فوراً أن لدينا شيفرة مُثبِّت صالحة لأن مولدات المُثبِّت تتبادل وهذه مجموعات مولدة
صغرى وفضاء الشيفرة غير تافه كما نعلم مسبقاً. لكن يمكننا أيضاً أن نرى بوضوح أننا
لا نستطيع توليد سالب واحد ضرب الوحدة. وإليكم شيفرة Shore ذات التسعة qubit وهي أيضاً شيفرة مُثبِّت
معبَّر عنها بمولدات المُثبِّت. في هذه الحالة لدينا أساساً ثلاث نسخ من شيفرة التكرار ذات الثلاثة
بتات واحدة لكل كتلة من كتل الثلاثة qubit الثلاث، بالإضافة إلى آخر مولدين مُثبِّت اللذين
يأخذان شكلاً يذكّر بالـ circuit الذي رأيناه في الدرس السابق لاكتشاف انقلابات الطور لهذه
الشيفرة. طريقة أخرى للتفكير في آخر مولدين مُثبِّت هي أنهما يأخذان نفس الشكل تماماً كما
لدينا لشيفرة التكرار ذات الثلاثة بتات لانقلابات الطور إلا أننا نستبدل XXX بـ X. والسبب
هو أن XXX يقابل عملية X على الـ qubit المنطقي المُرمَّز باستخدام شيفرة التكرار ذات الثلاثة بتات. لكن
هذه ملاحظة جانبية وليس شيئاً يجب القلق بشأنه الآن لو لم يكن واضحاً. بعد ذلك سنلقي نظرة على بضعة
أمثلة أخرى، لكن قبل ذلك دعوني أذكر أن الناس غالباً يحذفون رموز الجداء التنسوري عند وصف شيفرات المُثبِّت لأن ذلك يميل
لجعلها أسهل قراءة. فإليكم شكل هذه الشيفرات بدون رموز الجداء التنسوري
لكن بالطبع هذه جداءات تنسورية وليست جداءات مصفوفات عادية. نحن فقط نحذف رموز الجداء التنسوري لتكون أقل
ازدحاماً والأنماط أوضح. إليكم مثالاً آخر يُسمى
شيفرة Steane ذات السبعة qubit ولها بعض الميزات الرائعة حقاً. سنعود إليها
من وقت لآخر خلال الدروس المتبقية من الوحدة، لكن الآن يمكننا ببساطة التحقق من أنها شيفرة مُثبِّت
صالحة. وبالأخص أول ثلاثة مولدات مُثبِّت تتبادل بوضوح مع بعضها لأن Z يتبادل مع
نفسه والوحدة تتبادل مع كل شيء. والوضع مشابه لآخر ثلاثة مولدات فيبقى
التحقق من أنه إذا أخذنا أحد مولدات Z المُثبِّتة وأحد مولدات X المُثبِّتة فإنهما يتبادلان
ومن السهل مراجعة الأزواج التسعة الممكنة للتحقق من أنه في جميع هذه الحالات سيكون لدينا
X وZ متطابقين في نفس الموضع عدداً زوجياً من المرات فيتبادل المولدان تماماً
كما يتبادل XX وZZ. إنها مجموعة مولدة صغرى ولها فضاء شيفرة غير تافه لكن
لن أحاول إثبات ذلك في هذا الفيديو وبدلاً من ذلك أتركه لكم للتفكير فيه إذا أردتم. شيفرة Steane ذات السبعة qubit مشابهة
لشيفرة Shore ذات التسعة qubit بمعنى أنها تُرمِّز qubit واحد وتسمح بتصحيح خطأ عشوائي على qubit واحد لكنها تحتاج
فقط إلى سبعة qubit بدلاً من تسعة. وهذا ليس أقل عدد من الـ qubit المطلوب لشيفرة تصحيح أخطاء
لترميز qubit واحد وتصحيح خطأ عشوائي على qubit واحد. إليكم شيفرة مُثبِّت
تُسمى عادة شيفرة الخمسة qubit وهي أيضاً تُرمِّز qubit واحد ويمكنها تصحيح خطأ عشوائي على qubit واحد
وخمسة هو أصغر عدد من الـ qubit يكون هذا ممكناً فيه. إليكم مثالاً آخر على
شيفرة مُثبِّت رغم أنها ليست شيفرة بالمعنى الحقيقي لأن فضاء الشيفرة
أحادي البُعد. وبالأخص فضاء الشيفرة لهذه الشيفرة هو الفضاء المولَّد بزوج متشابك أو بعبارة أخرى حالة Bell في زائد
فلا يمكنكم فعلاً ترميز أي qubit باستخدام هذه الشيفرة لكنها ما زالت شيفرة مُثبِّت صالحة حيث فضاء
الشيفرة يصادف أنه أحادي البُعد. ومن الممكن فعل شيء مشابه لحالة
GHZ. إذاً هذه بعض الأمثلة على شيفرات المُثبِّت وسنرى عدداً لا نهائياً من الأمثلة في
الدرس التالي. لنفترض أن لدينا شيفرة مُثبِّت، السؤال الطبيعي الذي نسأله عنها
وربما أول سؤال يتبادر إلى الذهن هو كم qubit تُرمِّز؟ لهذا السؤال إجابة بسيطة
جداً. ولشرحها لنكن دقيقين بشأن شيفرة المُثبِّت المدروسة: لدينا R من مولدات المُثبِّت على n من الـ qubit
P1 إلى PR تستوفي المتطلبات الثلاثة التي ذكرتها سابقاً وهي أن
مولدات المُثبِّت تتبادل جميعها مع بعضها البعض وهذه مجموعة مولدة صغرى فلن نحصل على نفس
المُثبِّت لو أزلنا أحد المولدات وهناك على الأقل متجه غير صفري واحد في فضاء
الشيفرة. كما تشير المبرهنة الموضحة على الشاشة، يجب أن يكون بُعد فضاء شيفرة المُثبِّت
يساوي 2 أس n ناقص R. أو بطريقة أخرى يمكننا ترميز n
ناقص R من الـ qubit باستخدام هذه الشيفرة. فبشكل حدسي لدينا n من الـ qubit في ترميزاتنا وكل
مولد مُثبِّت يأخذ فعلياً qubit واحد من حيث عدد الـ qubit التي يمكننا ترميزها.
هذه المبرهنة ليست صعبة الإثبات وسأعرض لكم البرهان بعد قليل، لكن أولاً سنلقي نظرة على بعض
الأمثلة بدءاً بشيفرة التكرار العادية ذات الثلاثة بتات. لدينا ثلاثة qubit في
ترميزاتنا فـ n يساوي ثلاثة وهناك R يساوي 2 من مولدات المُثبِّت وبالتالي يمكننا ترميز qubit
واحد باستخدام هذه الشيفرة. لاحظوا أن هذا لا يتعلق بأي أو كم من الأخطاء يمكن اكتشافها أو
تصحيحها، فهذه مسألة مختلفة. هذا مجرد بيان عن بُعد فضاء
الشيفرة. كمثال آخر تأملوا شيفرة الخمسة qubit: هنا لدينا خمسة qubit وأربعة
مولدات مُثبِّت فمرة أخرى بُعد فضاء الشيفرة اثنان مما يعني أنه يمكننا ترميز qubit واحد باستخدام هذه
الشيفرة. ومثال آخر في الوقت الحالي: لشيفرة الزوج المتشابك المُثبِّتة لدينا qubit اثنان ومولدا مُثبِّت اثنان
فبُعد فضاء الشيفرة واحد. وكما ذكرت سابقاً هو الفضاء المولَّد بحالة Bell في زائد.
سنرى المزيد من الأمثلة مع المتابعة بما فيها شيفرات يمكننا فيها ترميز أكثر من qubit واحد، لكن الآن لنرَ
كيف يمكننا إثبات المبرهنة. أول شيء نحتاج لملاحظته هو أنه لأن مولدات
المُثبِّت تتبادل وتشكّل مجموعة مولدة صغرى، ولأن كل عملية Pauli هي معكوسة نفسها، فإن كل
عنصر في المُثبِّت يمكن التعبير عنه بطريقة وحيدة كجداء نرفع فيه كل مولد مُثبِّت
PK للأس AK حيث كل AK إما صفر أو واحد ثم نضرب النتائج
ببعضها. بطريقة أخرى نحصل على كل عنصر من المُثبِّت بضرب مجموعة جزئية ما من
مولدات المُثبِّت ولا نحصل أبداً على نفس عنصر المُثبِّت من مجموعات جزئية مختلفة. وشيء
يترتب على هذا هو أن الطريقة الوحيدة للتعبير عن عملية الوحدة على n من الـ qubit بهذه الطريقة هي أخذ جميع الأسس تساوي
صفر. بعد ذلك لنعرّف pi K كالإسقاط على فضاء المتجهات الذاتية بقيمة زائد واحد لـ PK لكل K من 1 إلى R وهناك
صيغة بسيطة لهذا الإسقاط: يمكننا ببساطة أخذ المتوسط بين PK والوحدة على n من الـ qubit مما يترك فعلياً القيم الذاتية
زائد واحد كما هي ويحوّل جميع القيم الذاتية سالب واحد إلى صفر.
الآن فضاء الشيفرة مُعرَّف كمجموعة كل المتجهات التي هي في آن واحد متجهات ذاتية بقيمة زائد واحد لجميع
مولدات المُثبِّت. بما أن مولدات المُثبِّت تتبادل فإن الإسقاطات يجب أن تتبادل أيضاً وهذا
يعني أن جداء هذه الإسقاطات هو أيضاً إسقاط وبالأخص هو الإسقاط على
تقاطع الفضاءات الفرعية التي تسقط عليها الإسقاطات الفردية أو بعبارة أخرى هو الإسقاط على
فضاء الشيفرة. يمكننا فك هذا الجداء وما نحصل عليه هو المتوسط على كل
عنصر من المُثبِّت. وأخيراً لأن بُعد أي فضاء فرعي يساوي
أثر الإسقاط على ذلك الفضاء الفرعي، نجد أن بُعد فضاء الشيفرة هو متوسط الآثار على عناصر
المُثبِّت. لكن باستثناء عملية الوحدة على n من الـ qubit فإن جميع عناصر المُثبِّت يجب أن يكون
أثرها يساوي صفر لأن مصفوفات Pauli الثلاث غير الوحدوية جميعها أثرها يساوي صفر. أثر عملية الوحدة
على n من الـ qubit هو 2 أس n وبالتالي نجد أن بُعد فضاء الشيفرة هو 2 أس n ناقص R وهذا يثبت
المبرهنة. بعد ذلك سأقول القليل عن كيفية ترميز الـ qubit باستخدام شيفرات المُثبِّت ولفعل ذلك نحتاج أولاً
لتقديم عمليات Clifford. عمليات Clifford هي عمليات وحدوية على أي عدد من
الـ qubit يمكن تنفيذها بواسطة circuit كمية بمجموعة محدودة من الـ gate وهي gate من نوع Hadamard وgate من نوع S
وgate من نوع controlled-NOT. لاحظوا أن gate من نوع T ليست مشمولة ولا gate من نوع Toffoli أو Fredkin
وليس فقط أن تلك الـ gate غير مشمولة في هذه القائمة بل في الواقع لا يمكن تنفيذ تلك الـ gate
باستخدام الـ gate المدرجة هنا، فهي ليست عمليات Clifford. عمليات Pauli من ناحية
أخرى هي عمليات Clifford وتحديداً يمكن تنفيذها باستخدام تسلسلات من gate من نوع Hadamard وS
إذاً هذه طريقة بسيطة لتعريف عمليات Clifford لكنها لا تشرح حقاً لماذا تُعرَّف بهذه
الطريقة أو ما هو المميز في هذه المجموعة المحددة من الـ gate. إليكم السبب الحقيقي لتعريف عمليات Clifford هكذا:
بتجاهل الطور الشامل، عمليات Clifford على n من الـ qubit هي بالضبط العمليات الوحدوية
التي تحوّل دائماً عمليات Pauli إلى عمليات Pauli بالقرينة. لنكون أكثر دقة، عملية وحدوية U على n من الـ qubit
هي عملية Clifford بتجاهل عامل طور شامل إذا وفقط إذا كان لكل عملية Pauli على n من الـ qubit
قرينة عملية Pauli تلك بـ U تعطينا زائد أو ناقص واحد ضرب عملية Pauli أخرى قد تكون مختلفة على n
من الـ qubit. يمكنكم التحقق بسهولة من أن هذه الخاصية صحيحة لـ gate من نوع Hadamard وS
وCNOT وبالتالي تنطبق بالضرورة على الـ circuit المبنية من هذه الـ gate. الأصعب إثباته هو الاتجاه
المعاكس وهو أنه إذا أُعطينا عملية وحدوية U معينة على n من الـ qubit تستوفي هذه
الخاصية فيجب أن يكون بالإمكان تنفيذها بتجاهل الطور الشامل باستخدام gate من نوع Hadamard وS وCNOT
فقط. لن أستعرض برهان ذلك الاتجاه لكنه صحيح ويمكنكم البحث عنه إذا كنتم
مهتمين. عمليات Clifford ليست شاملة للحوسبة الكمية بمعنى أننا لا نستطيع تشغيل حوسبة
كمية عشوائية باستخدام gate من نوع Hadamard وS وCNOT فقط. في الواقع لقيمة معينة من n هناك عدد محدود فقط
من عمليات Clifford على n من الـ qubit فهي مجموعة منفصلة من العمليات. فبعكس مجموعة
شاملة من gate الكمية لا يمكننا تقريب عمليات وحدوية عشوائية لأي مستوى دقة مطلوب. وفي
الواقع إجراء عمليات Clifford على حالات الأساس القياسي متبوعة بقياسات الأساس القياسي لا يمكن أن يسمح
لنا بإجراء حسابات خارج نطاق الخوارزميات الكلاسيكية لأنه يمكننا محاكاة حسابات من هذا الشكل بكفاءة
كلاسيكياً. هذه الحقيقة تُعرف بمبرهنة Gottesman-Knill والبرهان المعتاد لهذه المبرهنة مبني بمعنى ما
على صيغة المُثبِّت. وبالأخص الطريقة التي يعمل بها هي أنه يمكننا تتبع كيف تحوّل عمليات Clifford عمليات
Pauli بالقرينة وهذا يمكن فعله بكفاءة ثم نستنتج من ذلك ماذا تفعل الحسابات
بالـ qubit. فما علاقة هذا بشيفرات المُثبِّت؟ حسناً، شيفرة المُثبِّت توفر لنا
فضاء شيفرة ببُعد معين ولدينا الحرية في استخدام ذلك الفضاء كيفما نشاء. فلا شيء يُلزمنا بترميز
الـ qubit في ذلك الفضاء بطريقة محددة. لكن سيكون دائماً ممكناً إجراء ترميز باستخدام عملية Clifford
كمُرمِّز. وهذا جيد لأن عمليات Clifford بسيطة نسبياً مقارنة بالعمليات الوحدوية
العشوائية. هناك طرق لتحسين تنفيذها تعمل بخطوط مشابهة لبرهان مبرهنة
Gottesman-Knill ونتيجة لذلك فإن الـ circuit لتنفيذها لا تحتاج أبداً لأن تكون كبيرة
جداً. وبالأخص يمكننا دائماً إجراء ترميز باستخدام عملية Clifford تتطلب أقل بقليل من عدد تربيعي من الـ gate
لأن هذا صحيح فعلاً لكل عملية Clifford. فالخلاصة هي أنه لشيفرة مُثبِّت معينة يكون دائماً
ممكناً ترميز الـ qubit بكفاءة باستخدام تلك الشيفرة والأدوات الرياضية المفيدة لفهم عمليات Clifford يمكن أن تساعد في هذه
العملية. مثلاً إليكم مُرمِّزاً لشيفرة Steane ذات السبعة qubit. إنها عملية Clifford وكما يتبين
فهذه لا تحتاج حتى لـ gate من نوع S. لشيفرات المُثبِّت بشكل عام يعمل اكتشاف الأخطاء بالطريقة
التالية. كالعادة سنفترض أن لدينا مولدات مُثبِّت P1 إلى PR على n من الـ qubit ولنجعل E عملية Pauli على n من الـ qubit
تمثل خطأ افتراضياً على ترميز. نحن نعتبر فقط عمليات
Pauli كأخطاء بالمناسبة لأن تقطيع الأخطاء يعمل بنفس الطريقة لشيفرات المُثبِّت العشوائية كما يعمل لشيفرة Shore ذات التسعة qubit.
الطريقة التي نفحص بها الأخطاء هي قياس كل مولد مُثبِّت
كمرصود. هناك R من مولدات المُثبِّت وهذا يعني R من النتائج حيث كل واحدة زائد واحد أو ناقص
واحد أو قيمة ثنائية إذا فضلتم ربط صفر بزائد واحد وواحد بناقص واحد. وهذه النتائج R
معاً تُشكّل المتلازمة تماماً كما كان لدينا لشيفرة التكرار ذات الثلاثة بتات عندما كان R يساوي
اثنين. بشكل عام هناك ثلاث حالات ممكنة للخطأ E من حيث اكتشافه وهي كالتالي: أولاً
قد يكون E في المُثبِّت بمعنى أنه من الممكن توليد E من مولدات المُثبِّت أو
بشكل أعم قليلاً قد يكون E مكافئاً لعنصر من المُثبِّت بتجاهل الطور
الشامل. في هذه الحالة E ليس خطأ فعلياً لأنه ليس له تأثير في فضاء الشيفرة سوى
إدخال طور شامل محتمل وهذا ليس له أي تأثير. فلا نحتاج للقلق إطلاقاً بشأن أخطاء كهذه. أي فعل
غير تافه قد يكون لها يحدث خارج فضاء الشيفرة فهو لا يعنينا.
ما يثير القلق أكثر بكثير هو احتمال أن E ليس في المُثبِّت حتى بتجاهل الطور الشامل لكنه
مع ذلك يتبادل مع كل واحد من مولدات المُثبِّت. تذكروا أن
التبادل العكسي للخطأ مع مولد مُثبِّت هو ما يتسبب في ظهور سالب واحد في مكان ما في المتلازمة
لكن هذا لا يحدث في هذه الحالة. فهذا خطأ يغيّر فعلاً المتجهات في فضاء الشيفرة بطريقة
غير تافهة ونعلم هذا لأنه لو كان غير ذلك لكان متناسباً مع عنصر من المُثبِّت، لكنه يمر
دون اكتشاف من الشيفرة. فهذه هي الحالة السيئة: لدينا خطأ قد يغيّر
أي معلومات كمية رمّزناها لكن الشيفرة غافلة عن هذه الحقيقة. مثلاً لشيفرة التكرار ذات الثلاثة
بتات XXX تقع في هذه الفئة. والاحتمال الأخير هو أن E
يتبادل عكسياً مع واحد على الأقل من مولدات المُثبِّت وهذا يعني أن الشيفرة تكتشف هذا الخطأ لأننا
سنحصل على متلازمة فيها سالب واحد في مكان ما على الأقل مما يشير إلى أن شيئاً خاطئاً وسنحتاج لمحاولة تصحيح هذا الخطأ
بطريقة ما. إذاً هذه هي الاحتمالات. كمصطلح
عندما نشير إلى مسافة شيفرة مُثبِّت نقصد الحد الأدنى لوزن عملية Pauli التي تقع
في الفئة الثانية بمعنى أنها تغيّر فضاء الشيفرة بطريقة غير تافهة لكن الشيفرة لا
تكتشفها. وعندما نقول أن شيفرة مُثبِّت هي شيفرة [[n,m,d]] باستخدام
أقواس مربعة مزدوجة كما هو موضح على الشاشة فهذا يعني أن الترميزات بطول n من الـ qubit و
الشيفرة قادرة على ترميز m من الـ qubit فبُعد فضاء الشيفرة 2 أس m ومسافتها d. فالخطأ يجب أن يكون
بوزن d أو أكثر ليغيّر الحالة المنطقية لأي qubit رمّزناه دون أن يُكتشف
كخطأ. سنلقي الآن نظرة على شيفرة Steane ذات السبعة qubit كمثال وسنحدد ما هي مسافتها.
إليكم مولدات المُثبِّت لهذه الشيفرة. وتذكروا أن المسافة هي الحد الأدنى لوزن
عملية Pauli على n من الـ qubit التي تتبادل مع جميع مولدات المُثبِّت لكنها ليست في المُثبِّت ولا
هي متناسبة مع عنصر من المُثبِّت. ما سنحدده هو أن هذه الشيفرة مسافتها
ثلاثة. الطريقة التي سنحدد بها ذلك هي أولاً النظر في أي عملية Pauli بوزن اثنين على الأكثر وسنستنتج
أن الطريقة الوحيدة لتتبادل مع جميع مولدات المُثبِّت الستة هي أن تكون الوحدة التي هي دائماً عنصر من
المُثبِّت. فلنفترض أن مصفوفتي Pauli اللتين قد تكونان غير وحدويتين واللتين تشكّلان هذه العملية واللتين
سنسميهما P وQ تقعان في أقصى يسار موضعين. هذه حالة واحدة فقط ويجب علينا
النظر في جميع المواضع الأخرى المحتملة لمصفوفتي Pauli اللتين قد تكونان غير وحدويتين لكن الحجة هي نفسها أساساً لجميع
المواضع المحتملة. حسناً بالافتراض هذه العملية تتبادل مع جميع مولدات المُثبِّت الستة
فبالأخص تتبادل مع هذا وتتبادل أيضاً مع هذا.
Q تتطابق مع مصفوفة الوحدة في كلا المولدين ولهذا اخترنا هذين الاثنين. ولدينا مصفوفات
وحدة في أقصى يمين خمسة مواضع من هذا الخطأ وبالتالي نستنتج أن P يجب أن تتبادل مع كل من X
وZ لأنه لولا ذلك لتبادل هذا الخطأ عكسياً مع أحد هذين المولدين. لكن مصفوفة Pauli الوحيدة التي
تتبادل مع كل من X وZ هي الوحدة فيجب أن تكون P هي الوحدة. والآن بعد أن عرفنا ذلك
يمكننا اختيار مولدي مُثبِّت آخرين يحتويان على X وZ في الموضع الثاني من اليسار ويمكننا
استخلاص نتيجة مشابهة بخصوص Q. فلا توجد طريقة لخطأ بوزن اثنين على الأكثر أن يمر دون اكتشاف من هذه الشيفرة
إلا إذا كان مجرد عملية الوحدة التي هي في المُثبِّت فهذا ليس خطأ
فعلياً. من ناحية أخرى هناك عمليات Pauli بوزن ثلاثة تتبادل مع جميع مولدات المُثبِّت الستة
لكنها ليست متناسبة مع عناصر المُثبِّت وإليكم مثالين. فقد استنتجنا أن هذه
الشيفرة مسافتها ثلاثة. آخر شيء سنناقشه في هذا الدرس هو تصحيح الأخطاء لشيفرات
المُثبِّت. كالعادة سنفترض أن شيفرتنا محددة بمولدات مُثبِّت P1 إلى PR على n من الـ qubit
ولنبدأ بالتفكير قليلاً في جميع الأخطاء المحتملة التي يمكن أن
تحدث. هناك 2 أس R من المتلازمات الممكنة وكما ذكرت سابقاً في الدرس فإن هذه المتلازمات تقسم جميع
عمليات Pauli الممكنة على n من الـ qubit إلى مجموعات متساوية الحجم وهذا يعني 4 أس n مقسومة على 2 أس R من عمليات Pauli
في كل مجموعة. فعندما نرى متلازمة معينة قد يكون أي من هذه الأخطاء 4 أس n مقسومة على 2
أس R هو المسؤول. نحن نبالغ في العد قليلاً هنا لأن بعض هذه
الأخطاء لها نفس التأثير تماماً على فضاء الشيفرة. وبالأخص إذا كان لدينا خطأ E وضربنا E بأي
عنصر من المُثبِّت S فسنحصل على خطأ آخر له نفس التأثير تماماً في فضاء الشيفرة كـ E فهذه
أخطاء مكافئة. المُثبِّت يحتوي على 2 أس R من العناصر وإذا أخذنا ذلك بالاعتبار نجد
أنه لكل متلازمة هناك 4 أس n ناقص R من فئات التكافؤ غير المتكافئة للأخطاء التي يمكن أن تسبب تلك
المتلازمة. وما يعنيه هذا هو أنه ما لم يكن R يساوي n وفي هذه الحالة يكون فضاء الشيفرة أحادي البُعد
وبالتالي لا يمكننا ترميز أي qubit على الإطلاق، فلن يكون ممكناً تصحيح كل خطأ يمكننا اكتشافه. بدلاً من ذلك
ما يجب علينا فعله هو اختيار عملية تصحيح واحدة فقط لكل متلازمة على أمل تصحيح فئة واحدة فقط من الأخطاء المتكافئة.
فكيف نختار التصحيح المناسب لكل متلازمة؟ استراتيجية طبيعية هي اختيار
عملية Pauli ذات الوزن الأدنى التي تسبب أي متلازمة نقيسها بفكرة أن عمليات Pauli ذات الوزن الأدنى
تمثل تفسيرات أكثر احتمالاً لتلك المتلازمة. قد لا يكون هذا صحيحاً فعلاً
لبعض نماذج الضوضاء واستراتيجية طبيعية أخرى هي حساب الخطأ الأكثر احتمالاً الذي يسبب
المتلازمة المعطاة. لكن الآن سننظر فقط في الاستراتيجية التي نحاول فيها تصحيح الأخطاء باختيار عملية Pauli ذات الوزن الأدنى المسببة
للمتلازمة. لشيفرة مُثبِّت بمسافة d هذه الاستراتيجية ستسمح لنا دائماً بتصحيح أخطاء بوزن أقل
تماماً من نصف d أو بعبارة أخرى بوزن d ناقص واحد مقسومة على اثنين على الأكثر. وسأشرح بإيجاز لماذا
هذا صحيح. هذا سيُظهر مثلاً أن شيفرة Steane ذات السبعة qubit يمكنها تصحيح أي خطأ Pauli بوزن واحد وبفضل
تقطيع الأخطاء هذا يعني أنه تماماً كشيفرة Shore ذات التسعة qubit يمكن لشيفرة Steane تصحيح خطأ عشوائي
على qubit واحد. فإليكم كيف يعمل هذا: تصوروا أن هذه الدائرة تمثل جميع عمليات Pauli الممكنة
التي تنتج متلازمة كل شيء زائد واحد وهي المتلازمة التي تشير إلى عدم حدوث أخطاء
وأن كل شيء على ما يرام. بين هذه العمليات لدينا عناصر المُثبِّت أو حقيقة
عمليات متناسبة مع عناصر المُثبِّت ولدينا أيضاً أخطاء غير تافهة تغيّر فضاء الشيفرة بطريقة ما لكنها لا تُكتشف
بواسطة الشيفرة. ونعلم من تعريف المسافة أن كل عملية Pauli في هذه الفئة يجب أن يكون وزنها على الأقل
d لأن d مُعرَّف كالحد الأدنى لوزن هذه العمليات. لدينا أيضاً عمليات Pauli
تتسبب في ظهور متلازمات أخرى ويمكننا النظر في كل متلازمة على حدة لو أردنا لكن هنا نتخيل فقط
أن متلازمة ما S قد ظهرت. الآن تخيلوا أن E خطأ في هذه
الفئة بوزن أقل تماماً من نصف المسافة d. حسناً لا نعلم أن هذا
بالضرورة عملية Pauli ذات الوزن الأدنى في هذه الدائرة فلنأخذ C كعملية ذات الوزن الأدنى في هذه المجموعة أو إحداها في حالة
التعادل. فقد يكون C يساوي E أو ربما لا. لكن لأن C ذات
وزن أدنى نعلم أنه لا يمكن أن يكون وزنها أكبر من وزن E لأن C أيضاً في المجموعة
ولها وزن أدنى. فعملية التصحيح C يجب أن يكون وزنها أقل تماماً من نصف
d. فماذا يحدث لو طبقنا هذا التصحيح C على ما تصبح عليه حالتنا بعد الخطأ E؟
الإجابة هي أن الحالة التي نحصل عليها هي C ضرب E مضروبة في الترميز الأصلي لأننا أولاً
ضربنا بـ E وهذا كان الخطأ ثم ضربنا بـ C لمحاولة تصحيحه. وهذا الجداء يجب أن يكون في
المُثبِّت أو متناسباً مع عنصر من المُثبِّت وإليكم السبب: أولاً لأن E وC يعطيان نفس
المتلازمة فإن C ضرب E يجب أن يعطي متلازمة كل شيء زائد واحد. وذلك لأنه لمولد
مُثبِّت معين إما أن C وE يتبادلان معه أو يتبادلان عكسياً معه. يجب أن يكون نفس الشيء لكليهما
لأن المتلازمتين متماثلتان. وإذا فكرتم في ذلك لحظة فهذا يعني أن C ضرب E يجب أن
يتبادل مع جميع مولدات المُثبِّت. وأخيراً C ضرب E يجب أن يكون
في المُثبِّت لأن وزنه لا يمكن أن يكون أكبر من مجموع وزني C وE وبالتالي وزنه
أقل تماماً من d. وهذا يعني أننا نجحنا في تصحيح E لأن تطبيق E متبوعاً بـ C لا يفعل شيئاً
في فضاء الشيفرة. هذا رائع لكن هناك مشكلة واحدة فقط وهي أنه لشيفرات
المُثبِّت بشكل عام فإن حساب عملية الوزن الأدنى المسببة لمتلازمة معينة هو مسألة صعبة حسابياً.
وفعلاً هذا صحيح حتى للشيفرات الكلاسيكية التي يمكننا في هذا السياق اعتبارها شيفرات مُثبِّت
حيث تظهر فقط مصفوفات الوحدة ومصفوفات Z من Pauli كعوامل تنسورية داخل مولدات
المُثبِّت. فبعكس خطوة الترميز لا تنقذنا عمليات Clifford هذه المرة والحل المعقول
الوحيد هو اختيار شيفرات محددة يمكن فيها حساب تصحيحات جيدة بكفاءة. ولا توجد وصفة جاهزة
لذلك. ببساطة ابتكار شيفرات مُثبِّت كهذه هو جزء من فن
تصميم الشيفرات الكمية. وهذا مكان جيد للتوقف في هذا الدرس. أتمنى أن تنضموا إلي
في الدرس التالي الذي سنلقي فيه نظرة على بعض بنى الشيفرات الكمية المحددة بما فيها شيفرات تُجسّد فن تصميم الشيفرات الكمية
بطريقة مذهلة حقاً. إلى اللقاء